look at you guys oh you got the uh
embellishments as well yes i did i
picked it out myself
no i did not oh good
i trust my man
well we had a stylist who held but i was
like the final say and everything and he
i think he looks so handsome tonight
he's like shiny shimmering splenda you
look thank you i mean you guys are truly
bona fide reality tv stars but how does
it feel to be here rubbing elbows with
fellow reality stars i love it is like
insane it's probably like the most crazy
red carpet i've ever been to it's just
fabulous i love the energy love the
energy
listen now that you're not doing flip or
flop maybe it's time to cross over or
find another reality show to join what
do you think of that i would say we're
always working on it yeah you never know
there might be something coming soon we
might have an announcement you never
know but not right now but you know
coming up a whole bunch of announcements
you know i was going to ask heather if
you would ever be down to do a home
renault show with your man yeah my man
is so talented i've already learned so
much from him and i would love to get
into the flipping business more i love
real estate i'm in the business so why
not cross over yeah that makes sense
let's unless we have fun together we get
to film together yeah be together every
day well we already are but you know
even more
you know obviously there has been a lot
of attention paid to your guys's
co-parenting journey what do you wish
people knew about your modern family
were just like yours
we're just like yours so you know we
work really hard all of us and we try to
make decisions uh for what's the best
interest of the kids the kids are always
number one and communication is very
important i was gonna say what's the
biggest lesson you kind of learned
through this experience the kids are
always number one regardless of any
other thing going on in your life and
yeah exactly like speaking through
things communication and that's and
being happy for the children how would
you guys describe your relationship now
with your ex it's good
parenting and things are good yeah you
guys have also been so open about your
fertility journey what advice do you
have for women out there who can share
that sentiment oh my gosh it is a very
it's a struggle it's a lot of emotions
up and down and i'm lucky that i have my
husband and my step kids to be there for
me and a lot of people don't have that
but you know stay positive your journey
will come and um
just like there's a lot of love out
there and i'm always here to support
women and now because i went through it
so and also ice before you take the
shots
yes like ice put music on and just try
to keep a positive outlook now i read
that you're um waiting to have kids
until maybe later this year is that
still the case you know you never know
what's going to happen you never know
we can't predict the future so you might
be hearing some good news soon as well
there's a lot of women who can relate so
it's amazing that you've been so open
michelle's new relationship what do you
make of all that you know as long as
kishell is happy then i am happy because
i love her i adore her and she's just a
lovely person and christine is not
invited tonight she's not here
she is not not here she's not invited i
heard she was not invited if she shows
up that would be quite the story
you know what if she's in there make a
sign throw out the red flag okay i'm
like she's here
enjoy tonight you guys
[Music]